what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Carnage and the ending of
this is gonna blow your mind so check
this out this picks back up with Kenneth
Neely basically abandoning Carnage but
also being kicked out at the same time
and traveling to go see Cletus Cassidy
now a little bit of ketchup here because
we haven't done Carnage for a little
while for those of you guys who recall
Kenneth Neely was a guy who was obsessed
with the Carnage symbiote right just the
violence of it all just the the horror
of it all but he saw it as more of like
an artistic thing and so what he did is
he started effectively killing people in
order to draw the card and symbiote out
but the more time that Kenneth spent
with the Symbiote the more time he
realized he bit off more than he could
chew he didn't fully understand what he
was getting into But ultimately John
Shane who was basically a cop that was
hot on the trail of the Symbiote itself
ended up basically being Force merged
with the carnesty and we'll talk about
that here in a second but in an effort
to find a way to defeat the Symbiote
itself realizing that Carnage was
effectively attaining godhood Kenneth
traveled to visit Cletus now the funny
thing about this is remember Cletus has
a whole nother symbiote of his own right
the extreme symbiote extrembiate if you
want to call it that and the thing here
is that Cletus Cassidy and the Symbiote
just kind of exist out there in the
world but because of the nature of the
symbiote's power Cletus can effectively
alter reality in a localized space so
when Kenneth shows up here he
demonstrates yet again he has no idea
what he's doing because when he starts
talking to Cletus he kind of introduces
himself and says hey like I was a huge
fan of the Carnage symbiote and I'm a
huge fan of you and and I did so many
things to model myself after you right
and one of the funny things about this
is that Kenneth says like I'm like you
Cletus Cassidy and the response of
Cletus is oh I highly doubt that Kenneth
or I I highly doubt that you are very
much like me and literally he says I am
like you Mr Cassidy I'm an artist I've
transformed 33 people Exquisite little
spirals in map and Bone and the response
of Cletus is 33 well Kenneth that pretty
much makes us family now doesn't it
right 33 people my gosh Kenneth you've
killed 33 folks Cletus at that point
uses his powers over the Symbiote to
transform reality around them and he
says like this is a truck stop in Iowa
Kenneth right they bulldozed it shortly
after I passed through here I killed 49
people here and here you are telling me
how similar we are because you killed a
whopping total of 33 people golly gee
Kenneth how will I ever measure up right
it's just one of these amazing moments
because Cletus Cassidy and this is one
of the coolest things Cletus Cassidy has
always been synonymous with Carnage it's
always been that way in Marvel Cletus
has his own origin story but no one
thinks about Cletus in relation to
himself if they ever think about Cletus
they think about Carnage this is one of
the first times in the history of Marvel
when they actually start focusing on
these two aspects of the same character
in different ways where Cletus gets
focused on in one capacity and Carnage
gets focused on in another and in fact
that's one of the things that happens
here Cletus Cassidy actually takes
offense at the hubris of Kenneth the the
Kenneth will just show up where khalid's
Cassidy is and say I'm just like you
because like I've murdered a few people
right the fact that he would compare
himself to someone like Cletus whose
body count is in the thousands right the
thousands I mean you could it'd almost
be hard to keep track of the total
number of people that have been taken
out and one of the things he says is I
don't usually have a problem with
trespassers and sometimes we even play
fun little games of course that's a
reference back to like the content
creator who showed up at the orphanage
where Cletus resided and then didn't
understand what he was getting into and
Cletus killed him if you didn't see that
video that we did make sure you check
the link in the comment for the Cletus
or for the Carnage playlist because that
story was it's the best Cletus Cassidy
story that I think I've ever read and so
what happens is Cletus immediately
approaches Kenneth and says do you have
any idea what I've become right I'm
going to unmake you Kenneth I'm going to
Pare you down right to the minerals I'm
going to scrape you out of this world
and it's really Kenneth coming to the
realization he doesn't understand what
he's getting into that in his mind the
according to symbiote being as crazy and
Bonkers as it was that was just one part
of the equation that Cletus is more
reasonable more understandable no Cletus
is insane the Carnage symbiote became
the way it was because of the insanity
of Cletus right remember whenever it
comes to the Symbiotes they are kind of
blank slates if you want to call it that
when they're born if you want to use
that word I guess born is a weird phrase
I mean they literally get pooped out but
the thing about this is that when the
Carnage symbiote was just there it
bonded to Cletus the only real emotion
that it had was the shared hatred of
Spider-Man that the Venom symbiid had
and it simply got that because it was
procreated right so that hatred just
kind of passed on but outside of that it
was just a symbiote that was there when
it bonded to Cletus and Cletus Insanity
drove the Symbiote to Insanity that's
how it is so instead of Kenneth being in
some situation where he's going to like
the more reasonable person he's going to
the source of the insanity having no
idea what it is that he's about to do
and one of the things that happens is he
besieges Cletus and saying no but like
the Carnage symbiote is about to become
God it went to the real realm of hell
with mistress halif it killed or at
least took out malikith via curse right
it's absorbing these different like
codices whatever those are right because
Kenneth doesn't fully understand them
right but he's like he's attaining these
high levels of power these artifacts
that will increase what it is that he's
capable of and he's going to wage war
against the universe and probably
destroy it and so before we end up
finding out the response of Cletus we
end up jumping over to John Shea now
remember John shade was the detective
who was constantly trying to track down
the combination of Kenneth and Carnage
initially it was him just trying to find
Kenneth but as Kenneth started allying
himself with Carnage it turned into a
hunt for both but the the Escapade and
the desire to find the Symbiote LED John
shade on this just sort of Journey and
really this adventure that he had never
considered before he was a detective
operating in New York and like that was
it right the worst he had to contend
with was somebody like Kingpin but then
suddenly he was thrust into this
situation where he's traveling to other
dimensions he's going to like all these
places that he didn't even really know
existed and so his life and a lot of
ways had been totally turned upside down
but remember the one thing that the
Carnage symbiote basically respects more
than anything else is tenacity the
desire to go after the thing that you
want and to let nothing hold you back
and where Kenneth Neely was by all
standards of measurement a coward John
shade was not and so that's why the
entire time this story has been going on
Carnage has been keeping a watchful eye
on Jon so that when both Jon and Kenneth
were in the same place it kind of gave
the Carnage symbiote the ability to
choose and he chose Jon as his host and
so what he starts doing is going through
his memories he starts looking through
his entire life to see what kind of man
he really is and one of the things he
finds is an instance where his old
partner where John's old partner had
basically come across the Kingpin and in
fact his partner was losing it on
Kingpin himself the reason for this
being because of the fact that Kingpin
had basically had like four states
Witnesses killed in the span of 48 hours
which destroyed the police's case
against Kingpin now this happened while
he was mayor and a little bit of
information here for those of you guys
who don't know yes the Kingpin did
become mayor of New York this came as a
byproduct of a story that Marvel had
done not too long ago called secret
empire were basically Captain America
took out the entirety of the superhero
Community it was amazing I loved that
story again you'll find that Linked In
The Pen comment as well secret Empire
was a phenomenal story but what ended up
happening is that in a situation where
New York was kind of isolated they were
stuck in a place called the dark force
Dimension that Kingpin used his
authority to keep the people of New York
Safe knowing that in doing so they would
see him in a as a person who protected
them in a way that nobody else could
Daredevil Spider-Man none of those guys
so when everything went back to normal
Kingpin ran for mayor and achieving the
Loyalty of the citizens of New York he
won so it was a really really cool story
ultimately that ended in another story
that was called Devil's Reign but the
fact here is that this instance where
he's taking out State's Witnesses this
happens during that time when he's mayor
he's almost Untouchable and so what ends
up happening is Jon literally reels his
partner in and says no no trust the
system trust the justice system like
goodness will prevail here but it didn't
and the reason why is because John was
living to a degree in a fantasy land now
even John himself admits he was younger
he was naive and he trusted the justice
system that he worked for all the while
oblivious to the fact that there are
people out there like Kingpin who are
just immune to Justice right who by
whatever Manner and whatever means the
contacts they have the money they have
they're able to avoid any real
punishment for the crimes that they
commit that Jon had seen the justice
system as this fair all-encompassing
thing that would always ensure that good
prevailed this was reality and the funny
thing here is that his partner Clyde had
a much better understanding of how the
justice system worked than John did and
that ultimately as Carnage points out
good didn't Prevail nothing happened the
Kingpin just got away with what it was
that he'd done and that was it right
that was just the nature of the Beast
and so in a lot of ways Jon had kind of
betrayed his partner and so what it
shows here at least as far as Cletus
Cassidy is concerned is that the more I
guess no pun intended Shady version of
John shade is really just predicated on
him understanding the way in which the
world works that the world is not a
horrible terrible place but it's not a
great place the world is just apathetic
and it's just some people out there who
try to do the right thing but most
people are just minding their own
business and if it doesn't affect them
directly they don't care and that
mindset allows a lot of terrible things
to slip through the cracks and so
jumping back to Cletus Cassidy and to
Kenneth Neely Cletus warps reality
around them again to make it appear like
they're in a diner so it can seem like
they can have some kind of measure of
genuine conversation Have No Illusion
despite the fact that Pluto's Cassidy
just seems very relaxed and he's just
eating pancakes I mean he would kill
Kenneth Neely and forget that he did it
10 minutes after doing it right like the
value of life does not exist for Cletus
Cassidy right this is this guy lives his
life by two rules those he can kill and
those he can't and so what he does is he
tells Kenneth to take him through his
journey which is to say show me how it
is that you did these people in right
show me what your artwork looked like
and so using the memories of Kenneth
Neely Carnage restructures reality and
pulls up one of the crime scenes and
immediately Cletus rejects it he's just
like no this is not Carnage it's too
neat it's too structured why you got
this body displayed up you know a guy at
a zoo and even laughs at him about it
right like you know a guy who can give
you like these like butterfly larva that
you can put inside so when somebody cuts
it open that the butterflies emerge and
that kind of thing this is not Carnage
Kenneth Carnage is madness it's
unrestrained chaos that's what Carnage
represents if you really were anything
like me this room which is full of be
full of dead bodies and people who are
just screaming for their lives and in
their final moments experiencing abject
Terror that's what Carnage is this is
controlled this is restrained this is
just a guy who's a copycat and a poor
one at that and being taunted by Cletus
Cassidy in that way that Kenneth lashes
out and then goes to slash the throat of
of Cletus and then runs right takes off
running now remember everything that
you're seeing here right now is
manufacture good reality is altered
reality there's nowhere for Kenneth to
run to he's still inside the house he's
still inside this symbiote that Cletus
has control over and can make it look
like anything he wants and so there
comes a point when as Kenneth is running
that Cletus just appears to him and it's
just like you seem to have forgotten
your paintbrush my stroke right like
pulling up this scalpel that Kenneth had
and so at the end of the day the
question Kenneth has is why in the world
are you here right this is actually just
like this amazing shift in the mentality
of Kenneth because one of the things
that's the most overlooked about his
character is that he is a manipulator in
a lot of ways in fact Cletus even goes
so far as to give Kenneth his own story
and saying Once Upon a Time me and
Carnage really were the same person we
functioned in the same way but
ultimately we ended up parting ways when
I got the extreme symbiote Carnage
didn't really seem to like it that much
but I realized he was also restraining
me he was holding me back now this is
the story that comes in the aftermath of
absolute Carnage where it basically
shows how Cletus Cassidy and the
Symbiote basically separated but this
also illustrates that when Iron Man had
this symbiote that he was using right he
was using one part Celestial technology
and one part symbiote as a new form of
armor that Cletus took it over and when
he did it became his new host Simeon
right the extreme symbiote extrembiote
again whatever you want to call it here
but the thing about it is that Cletus is
almost taunted to a degree by Kenneth
right Kenneth says here's the problem
though Cletus while you're here in your
house and you're toying with people who
are unfortunate enough to stumble across
your path the world's forgotten about
you the world doesn't remember you
anymore whenever all these crazy
situations unfolded where the Carnage
symbiote and you along with it would
just go on these crazy murderous
Rampages nobody ever spoke the name of
Cletus Cassidy they spoke the name of
Carnage they don't remember your Madness
they don't remember your beauty or your
chaos the only thing you can do here is
to show them right and so what ends up
happening is Cletus basically re-dawns
the Symbiote on himself and then leaves
right like literally leaves alongside
Kenneth and they end up traveling to
what's basically a real World Diner and
so in order for Cletus to give Kenneth a
display of what Cletus himself is truly
capable of what beauty and art look like
to him he goes on a rampage in this
Diner and just takes these people out
and the most violent and chaotic way
possible this is very much a throwback
to Maximum Carnage from the 1990s and in
fact one of the things that happens here
is that one of the guys inside the diner
literally picks up his phone and goes to
make a phone call to call 9-1-1 now what
ends up happening is Kenneth steps in
and says no we can't have you doing that
here right like we can't have you doing
that my friend Cletus here has been
locked up for quite some time and he's
allowing himself for a kind of release
now this is an instance where Kenneth
completely misunderstands the situation
because where he goes to smash the phone
Cletus snatches it out of his hand and
says no do you still understand nothing
of what we're doing here right like I am
reminding the world who I am that
Carnage is not a better version of me
the Carnage is a poor man's version of
me I am the master I am the Maestro I'm
the artist I made Carnage what it is and
clean this Cassidy will be remembered
again so he tells this guy pull up your
phone call 9-1-1 like I'm gonna kill you
like I'm gonna take you out but I'm
gonna let you live a little bit longer
so you can basically make this phone
call which he does he alerts the
authorities on what's going on and then
once the authorities become aware and
they respond then ultimately this guy's
taken out now as you will notice here
the art style shifts and if you're
familiar with Marvel Comics right now
you know exactly what this art style is
you know exactly what comic this art
style comes from because in the midst of
all this chaos Spider-Man responds right
Spider-Man shows up here Spider-Man says
okay there's some major Calamity going
on I've got to respond to this and I've
got to see what's happening but it's not
Peter Parker Miles Morales responds to
the chaos Miles Morales is about to face
off against Carnage not only that Miles
Morales becomes Carnage with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end call of hangers thank you all
for watching and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]